new in theaters this weekend knives out
and Queen and slim will you see this is
your weekend ticket family has desperate
motives and Winkle people get desperate
but no come out you know something spill
it
I suspect foul play what a wealthy
successful crime novel writer meets an
untimely demise the day after his
birthday his family is conveniently
gathered to pay their respects and read
his will but a private investigator
suspects foul play and aims to shake
down this cast of crazy characters hey
speaking of cast the cast is impressive
and I'm gonna try and name them in one
breath Daniel Craig Chris Evans Jamie
Lee Curtis Don Johnson Michael Shannon
on a de Armas Jayden Martel Toni
Collette like Heath Stanfield Katherine
Langford and Christopher Plummer and
it's directed by Rian Johnson this
movies for you if you're a detective
crime drama buff you're excited to see
this all-star cast or if you think
Colonel Mustard did it in the library
with the lead pipe
got kilt who was self-defense after an
overly aggressive police officer
escalates a pullover with a black couple
the officer is shot dead in self-defense
leaving the couple on the run as labeled
cop killers and after a video of the
event spreads the couple unwittingly
becomes a symbol for the black community
this movies for you of an intense action
film sounds good to you you're excited
to see the film directorial debut of
music video director Molina Metsu kiss
or if you're a fan of love stories with
high stakes that is your weekend ticket
will you see and come back next week for
our holiday movie preview